when you look at the list of artists
with the most Grammy wins near the top
you'll find Stevie Wonder Beyonce you
too and Vince Gill with 21 Awards Gil
has more grammy wins than any other male
country artist in the 90's he won at
least one trophy every year over his
more than four decades career the
country star has played everything from
bluegrass to pop and rock he sold more
than 26 million albums and been invited
to join both dire straits and the Eagles
now with his 15th studio album Gil is
releasing some of his most personal
songs yet for his new album okie
Oklahoma born Vince Gill brought out
some old songs he'd been keeping in a
desk drawer she's forever forever
changed was written he says seven or
eight years ago
what made you pull that out now you
obviously see it on a daily basis yeah
what that songs about put your hands
where they don't belong
it's about sexual abuse is dead and gone
you had an incident yourself mm-hmm
yeah and I don't know that it came from
that because what happened to me was
basketball coach in seventh grade
tried to act on me in his office and his
hand on my leg and settled further and
further and so this doesn't feel normal
I jumped up and I ran out of the office
but I think what I want to convey in
that song most is just to tell people
somebody's hurting for them and that you
didn't do anything wrong
the album also includes a tribute to his
late friend Merle Haggard
[Music]
in the morning he died I just sat down
and wrote that song you needed to do
that yeah that's how I grieve is it yeah
I go to music for for grief it's cheaper
than therapy event scale started going
to music early growing up in Oklahoma
City this looks like your report card
yeah it could be it won't be good he
gave his first performance in 2nd grade
at the Cleveland elementary school I
played the House of the Rising Sun so I
knew the die was cast the first song I
sang in front of people hears about cat
house in New Orleans I bought this
guitar when I was 18 years old
Gil paid a small fortune for the vintage
Martin he'd take out on the road and
that 69 bucks that I bought this guitar
with with all the money I had it was
everything whose everytime this old
guitar
the things we've been through CFR and
built back in 1942 he'd have his first
hit song with the band pure Prairie
league in 1980
at that field awesome people to be on
American Bandstand solid-gold all these
cool shows you know after a few years
Gil left to go solo but his first few
albums didn't take off and in 1989 Mark
Knopfler asked him to join dire straits
is it a tempting offer at the time of
course while it would have solved an
awful lot of problems for me financially
yeah I said if you don't bet on yourself
how you gonna get anybody else to the
bet paid off on his next album
[Music]
with the title song when I call your
name they've had everything going
against it it was a four minute and 48
second waltz
it's a white at work I don't know it
just struck a nerve with people it was
the first of 17 straight top ten country
hits for Gil in the 90s five of which
went to number one
that earned him the 21 Grammys that line
his home studio he also became a highly
sought after collaborator performing
with hundreds of other artists including
his wife Amy Grant who he met recording
this duet
then a few years ago the Eagles
after the sudden death of Glenn Frey
asked Gil to tour with them
[Music]
I couldn't be more grateful that they
thought of me one more time
but he could feel Eagles fans were a
little suspicious
I get in front of their crowd you feel
this that's kind of holding your breath
when I'd start singing yeah like oh it's
not the guy it's not the guy I'm used to
and then after after a couple of verses
of this and that I could just literally
see them just go it's gonna be okay
he's been touring with the Eagles for
more than two years now would you keep
doing it absolutely I just like being
part of the band and I always have I was
always a little bit uncomfortable being
the focal point what were you
uncomfortable with just being noticed
I don't need preferential treatment you
don't have a posse I don't have much of
a posse and and I Drive myself pretty
much everywhere I go and and so I'm
somewhat abnormal really I think but in
my mind it feels normal so the Eagles
are playing three shows in Las Vegas
later this month and early October it'll
be the band's first live performance of
the iconic Hotel California album from
beginning to end and Vince will be there
he's he's a lovely guy and there's a
reason you know he gets asked to play
with everybody that's because he can
play just about anything you can sing
just about anything and he says he loves
that because he says it's hard it's a
harder job to make yourself fit in that
somebody else is doing something that
somebody else is doing he says it takes
better ears and it almost takes more
talent yeah I love turning points in a
person's career 1989 he's invited to
play with dire straits he that's on
himself yeah and it works you can hear
more from Vince Gill including the story
of how he first met Merle Haggard at an
old honky-tonk on today's CBS this
morning podcast listen on your favorite
podcast platform